[Musique]
oh
le projet c'était de faire un habitat
pas collectif mais participatif avec 12
12 familles et avec chacun évidemment
c'est ce qui la porte de ses dons de ses
capacités de son enthousiasme de ses
idées et puis de ses finances aussi pour
pouvoir faire quelque chose qui soit à
la fois agréable à vivre mais aussi dans
la simplicité le respect de la nature le
respect de l'autre l' écoute les valeurs
humaines finalement c'est ça cet éco
amour en plein parc régional de la
brenne et le nouveau lieu de vie de
nicole à 75 ans elle voulait vieillir
entouré dans une maison conforme à ses
valeurs
ossature bois isolation paille et au
dessus vous avez les panneaux
photovoltaïques pour l'électricité et
thermique pour le chauffage
donc je suis quasiment indépendante en
énergie disons
il ya un courrier c'est pour moi c'est
un peu vous facteurs du hameau alors oui
ben oui bah disons que je me suis
attribué cette cette tâche là parce que
ça me permet d'aller saluer les
collègues
et puis ben euh ils sont très occupés
moi ça me fait sortir tous les avantages
koala mes collègues ce sont jean marie
et frédéric leur maison n'est pas tout à
fait terminé bonjour les amis ou nicosia
vous faire une petite idée allez faut
verser le couple ne vit pas encore ici à
plein temps mais deux ans de travaux ont
permis de se faire une idée de ce que
sera la vie ou à me ce que j'ai trouvé
en arrivant ici c'est quand même du
respect les gens se respectent beaucoup
il n'y a pas de deux d'actes intrusif
disons et ça aide beaucoup à bien sentir
chez soi après de voir évoluer les
choses ensemble on est quand même que
3,3 maison en train de construire ça
peut aussi celles aidées des liens qui
font que voilà on progresse ensemble et
et c'est agréable
c'est très agréable
jean marie a entièrement conçu et
réalisé sa maison tout en
autoconstruction quelque chose
j'avais envie de construire une maison
qui nous ressemblent donc pour ce faire
je suis parti sur les routes de france
comptant un an et demi j'ai fait des
chantiers participatifs
pendant tout ce temps où j'ai appris à
c'est là que j'ai découvert la paille
etc
et si on est un petit peu habile de ses
mains on n'y arrive et puis quand on
sait pas on demande
et puis les avantages d'une d'un éco
hameau comme ça c'est qu'on n'est pas
tout seul et on a des voisins des
collègues des amis qui peuvent donner
leur avis et ça ne vous aide à éviter de
recommencer les choses qui auraient pas
été bien fait avec le terrain jean marie
a investi 80 mille euros et en ans de
travail à temps plein dans sa nouvelle
maison de 60 m² l'homme à l'origine de
cet éco hameau c'est lui christian
spécialiste de l'éco construction
il espère que la crise sanitaire et les
confinements successifs vont encourager
d'autres familles à se lancer dans
l'aventuré
si on n'a pas les compétences moi je
peux les accompagner sur mon métier je
suis formateur en habitat écologique et
on peut vraiment monte des chantiers
participatifs pour les gens combien
d'argent on peut vraiment en cd en fin
de compte les uns aux autres pour
pouvoir justement arrive à construire
quelque chose mais ce qu'il faut surtout
c'est penser petit déjà en écologie pas
pensé faire une grande maison où quitte
à agrandir par la suite comme il faisait
les anciens du bon sens
on
[Musique]
de la campagne à la ville l'habitat
participatif gagne du terrain peu à peu
à saint jean de braye cette nouvelle
forme d'habitat a été initiée par la
commune et une poignée d'habitants une
co-construction avec le bailleur social
france loire qui aura pris sept ans dans
ce hameau partagé chacun vit chez soi
autour des espaces communs et d'un grand
jardin propriétaire d'un appartement
almeria a choisi de s'investir à fond
dans la commission jardin du hameau
partager et j'ai fait qu'on trois heures
en décembre
c'est des heures qu'on déclare inscrits
loser mais c'est des heures virtuel un
petit peu d' esclavage moderne si vous
voulez un les consenti consenti à oui
oui puis beaucoup de caractère donc
celui qui voudra me donner des ordres et
les poneys
c'est l'atelier où chacun peut venir
poncet bricoler faire une étagère
c'est pas mon truc mais ça sert aussi de
réserve pour les outils ici on partage
presque tous des outils pour le jardin à
la conception des logements
la casa nous et le lieu de convivialité
du hameau où les habitants aiment se
retrouver
l'idée c'est de faire beaucoup
d'activités ensemble plus possible ce
soit des ateliers cuisine et jardinage
de pouvoir connaître ses voisins de se
rendre service ça fait toute la
différence
alors qu'avant être à côté des inconnus
je trouve ça dommage c'est tout le monde
pouvait comme ça être ami avec ses
voisins je pense que le monde
fonctionnerait autrement à puteaux
dictatures amies avec ses voisins non
mais on n'est pas obligés de s'entendre
là je vous assure que tout le monde ne
s'entend pas mais mais voilà les moments
conviviaux comme ça
les habitants ont emménagé en novembre
dernier la plupart en location avec des
loyers modérés
cathy a passé trente ans sur les routes
comme chauffeur poids lourd
elle vient de poser ses valises au
hameau partager ici au moins c'est un
partage c'est pas forcément une
obligation on fait les choses c'est très
bien mais s'il ya une réunion on ne
vient pas ça n'a aucune importance si la
galette par exemple on vient pas c'est
notre choix on a chacun nos choix et on
va jamais venir frapper à la porte
c'est pas intrusif c'est donc ça
ressemble à ça donne beaucoup plus envie
de faire les choses
au coeur du hameau partager la maison
des 5 et une colocation original jimmy
lionel lysienne et xavier ont tous été
victimes de lésions cérébrales il
partage cette maison accompagnée par une
éducatrice spécialisée et une aide à
domicile
faites attention les doigts voilà vous
pouvez les couper en deux je me retrouve
des gens qui sont comme moi quoi chacun
son handicap
moi je ne sais plus lire malheureusement
moi je ne sais pas ce que c'était que la
gauche la droite
en fait j'ai toujours appris il est des
problèmes de nature respectée
psychotraumatiques l'ania donc après de
multiples tentatives comme tout a échoué
en vie dieu c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai pu me fit preuve que trop
bien que fait vrai que le conte probable
qu'on révèle mais productive
les locataires de la maison des 5 sont
des habitants comme les autres du hameau
partager ils pourront participer à
toutes les activités proposées tout
contact avec les hommes tous dit
ouverture sur le vivre ensemble est
important pour leur compte et que
reconnu tiff
le problème est bien souvent de se
renfermer sadness une ouverture et une
ouverture qui est bon ils n'ont pas à
faire
véritablement le premier pas c'est
organisé une double inclusion rares et
vertueuse unique en région centre val de
loire
[Musique]
je me sers des érections tour dans l'éco
quartier montconseil à la découverte du
béguinage un mode de vie basé sur une
entraide
c'est pourquoi oui en fait il ya
toujours quelqu'un qui est là en fait
quand on a besoin de quelque chose ou
même besoin de voir quelqu'un on fera
pas n'importe quelle porte ya toujours
quelqu'un derrière et qui est très
bienveillant et qui nous ouvre voilà
avec plaisir et voilà le béguinage est
née au moyen âge pour protéger les
femmes seules il revient en france
portée par une association
son objectif permettre aux habitants de
la résidence de rester autonome le plus
longtemps possible grâce au soutien des
autres sur les seuls marchés mais moi le
matin c'est du ralenti à l'appui j'ai
peur de tomber les quinze locataires du
béguinage les béguins ont chacun leur
appartement et leur indépendance a les
images je vous en prie le passé avant ce
matin bah écoute et oui la barre mais
oui en cas de besoin ils peuvent
toujours compter sur laurent gardien
veilleurs mais aussi dépanneur nous
emmène au deuxième
joli coup alors qu'est ce qui vous
arrive est capricieux 1
est-ce que c'est bon mais c'est tout bon
il nous rassure alors il nous rassure
d'abord quand on a un petit problème
technique
quand on a un portable qui ne marche pas
quand on a un outil informatique qui
vont qui est effectivement aussi
capricieux quand même fait ce que je
peux bien évidemment et il rassure aussi
avec les mots souvent autour d'un café
je peux faire le lien et le rôle est en
fait sur suivant une peut-être une
petite altercation qui ait pu y avoir
entre deux personnes
et c'est vrai que certaines peuvent
venir me voir et m'en parler et pour le
coup baisse alors ça leur fait du bien
aussi de pouvoir en parler au moins ça
libère un petit peu le lait l'état
d'esprit deuxième garante du vivre
ensemble c'est béatrice vous pour être
sûr qu'il est toujours d'actualité ce
contrat fin je ne vois pas pourquoi il
ne serait engagé pour gérer les petites
anicroches du quotidien elle accompagne
aussi les béguins dans leurs démarches
administratives
c'est pour une assurance décès qu'on
avait pris et qui arrive à la fin alors
je vous allez voir ce qu'ils me disent
alors je préfère que béatrice et nous
guide chercher mais tu as bien fait
[Musique]
depuis le début de l'épidémie
les ateliers comment sont rares mais les
après midi je reste incontournable au
béguinage et ben j'aime bien parce que
ça me fait travailler la mémoire parce
que quand on est tout seul c'est ça que
je m'apercevais je perdais moi ça fait
que cinq ans et demi de mon mari est
décédé
mais quand on est tout simple comme on
parle plus et bon père et ses sacs et
agréable d'être ensemble parce que ça
fait travailler ses importants face à l'
isolement
la vie en béguinage revient comme une
solution pour bien vieillir chez soi
les loyers y sont un peu plus chers que
dans un logement classique entre 420 et
750 euros selon les moyens de chacun et
la taille de l'appartement
le prix du fonctionnement de
l'association vivre en béguinage qui
assure un accompagnement quotidien à ses
locataires
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]